the seafood you buy at the supermarket
may not always bleep be what it says on
the label it says two-month to none you
end up getting scrod a new report out
this morning found one in five samples
of fish tested from markets and
restaurants were mislabeled the u.s.
imports about 90% of its seafood but
once those shipments cross the border
the report says they are rarely tracked
all the way to your table Anna Werner is
here to explain and a good morning good
morning well if you order snapper at a
restaurant you expect to get snapper and
you might be upset to learn if it's not
but this new report finds that may be
happening with your seafood more often
than you think wherever we tested we
found mislabeled seafood Beth Lowell
with advocacy group Oceana has been
working to stop seafood fraud for nearly
a decade the consumer thinks that
they're getting a high-priced fish and
instead they're getting the cheaper
alternative when they are being ripped
off the group collected 449 samples from
restaurants small markets and grocery
stores in 24 states and DC and found one
out of five samples were mislabeled one
in every three businesses visited sold
at least one item that was not labeled
correctly the biggest offenders snapper
and sea bass with 42% and 55% of the
samples found to be fraudulent well the
problem is seafood fraud can happen any
time in the supply chain where one fish
is swapped out for another it could
because somebody wants to sell a cheaper
fish at a higher price or if they're
trying to fill all the orders for salmon
and there's not enough salmon they may
swap something else out
not only can that fraud cheat consumers
but Oceana reports it continues to find
vulnerable species those that have been
overfished mislabeled some restaurants
are now focusing on using only local
sustainable fish these are shots my
enoki is a tiny sushi restaurant in New
York City where you won't find the
famous but threatened bluefin tuna says
owner TJ Provenzano
you know I always make the joke you know
we don't sell bluefin tuna and we don't
sell cheetah you know it's why are we
able to you know have one endangered
species
menu in New York City and not another
one it's confusing to me so instead of
the usual tuna and salmon chef Jeff
Miller creates sushi featuring regional
species like the one named Blu runner
commonly known as baitfish the perfect
American sushi fish right here and it's
so overlooked and I feel like I'm in on
on a huge sushi secret as a result
Provenzano doesn't have to worry much
about fraud and that's what we say all
the time is the fish that we're serving
nobody would want to fake and it's a
good thing for the guests as well and
you know let me be frank there is no
sacrificing quality when it comes to
eating these things they are absolutely
beautiful species that are just kind of
underappreciated but with most
restaurants still serving imported
seafood Oceana says the government needs
to keep better track of which species
are going where we mean to be tracking
seafood from the fishing butter farm all
the way through the supply chain last
year the government started a monitoring
program for some seafood but Lowell says
only 13 species are tracked and once in
the US they're no longer followed now
NOAA the government NOAA the government
agency responsible for the program told
us that it tracks seafood that is quote
particularly vulnerable to illegal
unreported and unregulated fishing and
seafood fraud says the program was not
designed to trace seafood products after
they enter the u.s. market really
interesting but biana why do you think
we did this story just for the halibut
just for the hell
[Laughter]